[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
i can't help but feel like we're
forgetting something
they aren't coming back are they
nope
[Music]
luke and becca here with the outdoor
boys youtube channel and we are going on
a spear fishing date in the florida keys
this is our first time ever leaving the
kids
to go out of town and we're also
celebrating our 20th wedding anniversary
we're older than we look
so me and becca are headed to the isle
of murata and we are gonna spend two
days count them two days
spear fishing and catching and cooking
and it's gonna be
magical
[Music]
sweet corn fritters
oh i think this is the right house oh
this looks nice this is not the couch
for kids but it looks very nice well i
was gonna say white the kids will ruin
it they're not here it's a little bit
late and we've got an exciting day
tomorrow so i'm gonna put the camera
down and i will see you
in the morning
oh what a lovely day today
all right becca you ready to go scuba
diving i'm ready
guys we're back here at isla murada with
forever young spear fishing if you guys
remember last spring we took the whole
family spear fishing for invasive
lionfish here and we had so much fun we
do so many charters and this was hands
down one of the favorite we have done in
years so we're back here we're gonna
spend two days spearfishing scuba diving
becca is certified with scuba so she's
gonna be scuba diving i'm gonna be free
diving i can't tell you how excited i am
for this oh look at this guys it is a
beautiful day
well guys we just did a short little jog
out of the harbor and uh
we're getting ready to get in the water
i'm so excited
look at how clear that water is
all right guys i learned a valuable
lesson last time we came down here
i am not getting sunburned this time
looking sharp so we're gonna take it
easy this first dive we're going
somewhere shallow and a beautiful nature
preserve so no spear fishing just
beautiful beautiful scenery here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
well that was amazing but i'm ready to
poke some fish
it's got all sorts of stuff coming out
oh yeah
a whole bunch of gear to compensate for
my lack of skill
the very first spot we went spear
fishing tony dove down to go check
something out and he comes up makes the
sign for shark and points over to like a
seven foot bull shark just chilling
but tony and the sharks seem pretty
chill about it so i just dove down on
these coral heads and pretty soon i
found myself a spiny lobster and i had a
devil of a time wrestling that thing out
of there but this was my very first
spiny lobster ever it was really fun i
was also pretty happy because this was
35 feet of water and last time i dove
with tony diving 35 feet was a real
struggle for me and this time it was
pretty comfortable so i really felt like
i was making some improvements
not too much after that we found a
couple invasive lionfish sitting on
these little coral heads
lionfish are an invasive species here in
the keys and they're also extremely
tasty so i was very happy to get this
that's what i call a sucker pudge he was
looking right at you
that is a big boy
now this same coral head also had a
spiny lobster hiding deep inside it
[Music]
well that didn't work too well so we
went and got a tickle stick and a net to
try to get that lobster out of the hole
and this little stingray ended up
swimming right in my face and scared the
bajeebies out of me
after failing more times than i like to
admit i had tony go down there and he
got that lobster right out of there
well guys that was awesome we got two
lionfish and two lobsters i mean becca
we're eating good tonight
we're gonna go try another spot let's do
it best anniversary ever good i love you
all right guys we're here at a new spot
and we're dropping a little bit of chum
so
we got this thing that looks like a
stinky loaf of bread just sitting in the
bag
and uh
and we're gonna see if the fish like our
fish loaf apparently uh we're also
putting out a large life insurance
policy on me and rubbing me in tuna oil
it was becca's idea
happy anniversary
tony's chum worked like a charm and
pretty soon we had thousands of fish
coming up right in our face but i'm not
really good with my fish identification
so it took a little bit of time for tony
to teach me what to aim for
then i started missing
a lot
repeatedly
over and over again
oh it was painful
but tony is an absolute professional and
he found a fish i couldn't miss
this is actually a really big lionfish
and it was in about 44 45 feet of water
so i was actually really happy to spare
this thing and it helped shake some of
the bad mojo off
that's a proper lionfish we saw a lot of
mangrove snappers down there so i dove
back down to about 40 feet ran into a
bull shark and that distracted me so
much i forgot to miss so i actually got
i actually got a fish but that whole
time i was just thinking that shark's
gonna come after that fish so i got it
up as quick as i could
that bull shark gave me pause
he swam right in front of me
a few successes helped me relax and i
started making shots
i ended up landing this yellowtail
snapper and i got my pole spear out and
managed to get a mangrove snapper as
well
we got a massive lionfish a good-sized
yellow tail and some mangrove snappers
and i did it with the bull shark
swimming around underneath this which i
thought was kind of neat
becca's got the lobster gloves she's got
the tickle stick and the net you guys
are going to catch some lobster
so this is a tickle stick it's got a
little bend to it you reach behind the
lobster you goose him
tickle his bottom and he gets freaked
out by that
walks out and you scoop him up with the
net
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
they were so busy
oh that was so much fun i would be so
depressed if we had to fly back today
but we're only halfway done
i'm still looking forward to tomorrow
this was awesome
we just rinsed all the gear off with
fresh water the manatees are just
gobbling it up look at that
that lionfish i think is bigger than my
mangrove snapper
that is a massive lionfish
proper size
yeah
you can see your bullet hole there now
for those of you guys who don't know
very delicious fish but a little bit uh
toxic if you get stung by some of the
spines it'll give you a nasty reaction
it's nice and painful
all right becca
shall we go get cleaned up and go to
dinner let's get clean up and go to
dinner
well we've got our lobsters a couple of
the lionfish and the yellowtail and
we're going to take it across the street
here to chef michaels
uh they're going to cook it up for us
tony young said it was a really good
place to eat and we're excited to try it
out
i feel kind of trashy though showing up
to a restaurant with a garbage bag full
of fish
all right
all right we just dropped off a big bag
full of fish at the front and we're
gonna sit down and see what they turn it
into i'm really excited they've got tons
and tons of options but i kind of just
told them you guys do whatever you think
is best and
we'll see what happens oh look at this
big wow the first lobsters here look at
that
that was good you want to try it yeah
oh that's good
good
oh we got to catch some more lobsters
that was good oh look at that
that is gorgeous really pretty
it's a good sized wine fish yeah
this is the ponchatrine it's a creamy
creole shrimp and crawfish oh nice okay
and then this one is a tight chili sauce
gonna try the second lobster that's the
lobster ambassador right there
the key lime butter in there
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that
well guys that was an awesome meal and
it was actually way less than i thought
it was going to be it was very
affordable if you guys want to check
this out check out chef michaels i'll
put a link down in the video description
below
well good morning it's another beautiful
day are you ready to go out scuba diving
and snorkeling some more
no
i'm not
so tired we went to bed at what
8 30 i think
that was awesome
here we go it's seven in the morning
we're back here at the docks
tony and tj have another chart of going
out
so we are here with jeff
and luke what's up guys this has four
vans on it and you got it rigged up for
um for which we call it have a buoy on
it yes we're gonna have a float line or
a breakaway that's cool
[Music]
there may be some sharks around all
right guys we're trying something a
little different today we're out in the
blue water here above a wreck
and we're going to try to spear some
pelagic species you know pelagic means
the open water species
so we could see rainbow runners and
yellow tails maybe a wahoo or permit i
mean there's all sorts of things
possible but because of this we're
bringing
the big gun but uh we're gonna throw out
a bunch of flashers which look like
hookless fishing lures and we're gonna
dangle those to try to track fish up
from the deep or maybe throw out some
bait and we're in about 115 feet of
water here so we're not going down to
the bottom we're gonna we're gonna hang
out at the top here we go
so
[Music]
well i dove down and i took this shot at
a yellow tail and i missed him but just
the sound of my spear gun brought those
bull sharks in
we're changing spots because those
sharks were a little bit aggressive one
of the sharks hit my spear and just kind
of to see if there was anything on there
so those are some pretty well trained
sharks we saw a lot of rainbow runners a
few bar jacks and yellow tail it was
cool
i love you baby
well things went a lot smoother at this
next spot i ended up jumping in the
water and immediately shooting this
rainbow runner which is a wonderful
eating fish
but it was also kind of frustrating
because there was this school of rainbow
runners and they were there and i was
trying to reload and get another one as
fast i can and this gun takes so much
time to reload and then you miss and
it's like another three to five minutes
to reload
and i finally go and hit another fish
and it tangles itself up in the flashers
and so i decided that maybe it would be
just better if i started using my pole
spear
well there we go i picked up three
rainbow runners and i figured out a
secret to spear fishing aiming for the
fish and not over the fish is really
important apparently but i also dove my
deepest ever i went down 55 feet and i
got to see the shipwreck it was really
cool
rebecca's been really funny she kind of
wants to try spear fishing but
she's kind of on the fence about it so
we're going to go to a next spot here
and she's going to scuba dive and we're
going to try to see if she could get a
lionfish and i'm going to come along and
just kind of kind of watch and see what
happens
[Music]
[Music]
so
oh
[Music]
wow
[Music]
wow
[Music]
that nurse shark was all up in your
business
there's becca's lionfish
[Music]
natural born spear fisherman who knew
all right we're gonna go try another
spot all right guys we're here at
another spot we got some gorgeous
visibility and my gorgeous wife here is
gonna do some more scuba diving
[Music]
so
me
[Music]
what a great day yeah just an amazing
time
happy anniversary becca
official
horrible but i don't know but if i'm not
mistaken that is about the uh corner of
a spear a spear gun that's the reload
yeah
i thought i would have sufficient
padding down there yeah i almost had a
runny note like a slice
well i'm excited to try out these
rainbow runners i've never eaten one
before
there we go
and that's a serta you said uh
cyril
the king of the jungle right there the
lion fish definitely got a lighter meat
than the other mackerel i've had yeah
let's see this guy yeah there's a big
barracuda right there
oh that was cool
got a meal or two there look at that
i'm anxious to try these bad boys out
hey becca did you have a good time i had
a great time oh i did too we love going
with this charter if you guys ever find
yourself in the keys make sure to look
up forever young spear fishing charters
all right guys we're here at lazydays
about a mile or two down the road and
we're gonna see if they're gonna cook
our catch for us
there's a couple things you gotta get
when you go to the keys key lime pie
kong critters
so this one
we got the fish cooked lazy day style
so it's basically panko parmesan cheese
tomatoes scallions and a key lime butter
on it and one of them has a little bit
of jalapeno and one of them has none got
some coleslaw and some rice this is so
much food i can't believe we ordered
appetizers
oh my goodness guys i am so full and i
think our donkey bag is bigger than the
bag we brought in i think we got a
loaves and vicious situation here
i am full and tired babe how about you
me too
i fall asleep
all right guys the sun's up and so are
we and we are going to go get some
breakfast you ready becca let's do it
the western breakfast burrito with hash
browns looks good that looks amazing you
got it i got the hungry permit here
oh this is nice it's gonna be hard to go
back to real life
we're watching a bunch of people feed
tarpon over here off the docks i think
we might have to go try that there you
go
look at this
hey what are you staring at
hey hey move move
all right
it totally bit my head
terrorists
go away
all right becca you want to do it i'm
not sure now you're you're bleeding and
oh that's just that's just a little kiss
that is a massive tarpon look at the
size of that thing are you gonna go for
it oh he's staring at you
[Laughter]
do you want to do the last one
if you guys want to do this uh the
restaurant's called robbie's it's just a
little bit south of isle of murata
all right guys it's time to check out
i want to drive all right let's do it
baby
[Music]
[Music]
we hope you enjoyed this video as much
as me and becca enjoyed filming it if
you want to see more videos from the
outdoor boys youtube channel don't
forget to click subscribe we put out new
videos every saturday morning and check
out our travel and adventure playlist
for all of our amazing travel adventures
i'll put links in the video description
below and links to our merchandise down
below see you next saturday if you like
this video don't forget to check out the
outdoor boys youtube channel where we
have hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
saturday morning and hit that bell
button you'll get notifications thanks
for watching